the Department of Homeland Security may
reassign up to 2,000 more officers to
handle a surgeon a surge rather of
immigrant families entering the US
illegally through Mexico DHS secretary
Kirsten Nielsen says quote the crisis at
our border is worsening and DHS will do
everything in its power to end it the
potential shift of personnel follows
president Trump's threat to shut down
the border with Mexico and well borkus
is at the border in El Paso Texas with
more on this story man well good morning
to you good morning you can see just how
early people start to cross here
thousands in either direction every day
going to work or school so a border
shutdown would clearly have an immediate
economic impact here but the ripple
effect could be felt across the country
okay watermelon oranges cilantro
cantaloupes avocados at Junior's Farmers
Market in Houston the newly opened
family-owned business gets more than
half its produce from Mexico the borders
were disclosed I don't know I feel like
it could be a big impact on us nearly
half of all US imported vegetables and
40% of the nation's imported fruit are
grown in Mexico a border shutdown could
threaten more than six hundred eleven
billion dollars in yearly cross-border
trade and impact nearly 5 million jobs
nationwide hundreds of millions of
dollars of exports to Mexico are leaving
this plant Gerry Pacheco the president
of the border industrial Association
took us to an industrial park in Santa
Teresa New Mexico near El Paso to see
businesses that rely on cross-border
trade you'd put a lot of people out of
out of work and that's Americans not
Mexicans Pacheco says the impact of a
border shut down would be devastating
and not just here the supply chains all
the way back to the Midwest our auto
industry our AG industry would be
affected immediately so you were saying
that it wouldn't just be a hit on the
border it would be it would have a
ripple effect it would have a nationwide
and a global effect Border Patrol is on
track for more than 100,000
apprehensions in March the majority
family units and unaccompanied minors
and what that has effectively done is
oversaturated the immigration system
and that was never designed to deal with
this flow DHS has released thousands of
asylum seekers into the u.s. others have
been sent to Mexico to await their court
hearings The Associated Press is
reporting the White House is now
considering appointing a so called
immigration czar to oversee immigration
policies across multiple federal
agencies John Manuel thank you